it turns out that EA was not happy with
star wars battlefront score but are
currently working on a sequel with
greater depth I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update speaking today
during EAS Investor Day event EA Studios
boss Patrick soderlund talked about how
star wars battlefront while generally
well-received was criticized for its
lack of a single player campaign he also
teased that a future installment might
introduce a campaign something that even
Star Wars actor John boyega is called
for the omission of a single player
campaign was a conscious decision to get
the game out in time for the release of
the force awakens but söderlund said
that he was not pleased with the games
average review score right now it sits
at around a 75 on gamespot sister site
metacritic i think the team created a
really good game based on the premise
that we had are we happy with the 75
rating know is that something we're
going to cure going forward absolutely
so Dylan also spoke about ea's focus in
building new games the depth and breadth
is something that's proving to be more
and more important he said in a world
where we want sixty dollars up front and
we expect people to stay with us over
the course of a long time the depth of
what we offer is important last week EA
CFO Blake Jorgensen revealed that EA was
working on a battlefront sequel that
would feature content from the new
movies and include bigger and better
worlds you wish battle friend had had a
single player campaign let me know in
the comments or come and find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming
entertainment news keep it gamespot